hi guys it's silver it again and this
time we're going to again do some
preparations but this time more coaster
wise so that means getting the base of
the station done and also doing the
brake runs and lifts tail stuff but I'll
talk more about that later first I want
to add the station covers now you might
be thinking why at station covers well
mmm
realistic than realistic that's
basically it
Plus this CTR doesn't have it but um
I'll just build another coaster next to
it just to showcase that it will have to
be an in-game window so for example I
can just take the corkscrew coasters and
what just one goes to what the hell am I
talking about right so you take that and
then you you're left with this ugly
in-game station thing and you don't want
that at least I don't I I'm not sure
what you think of it but I don't like it
I'm not really sure anyone really likes
this kind of texture it's not realistic
that's for sure so what you're going to
do is you're going to take this set or
another set of your liking but this I
just like this set the most and you get
the station platform also known as the
in the infamous station cover and BAM
and that's why you place those now of
course this CTR is great so it doesn't
have those station thing is to begin
with but it's still realistic to add
station covers because you don't want to
step up 2 meters before you can actually
enter the station
I mean enter the car so that's why you
add those things right so with that out
of the way you can pretty much build the
rest of the station you need to build
those things first because otherwise you
won't know and what height you'll have
to build the floor but if you've got
this you want to built the floor at the
same height as the top of the station
cover and what I what I actually see
many people doing is they're going to
take their floor and they're going to do
what the game wants you to do or what
the game does and that's this they're
going to make the floor a bit lower than
the station cover and that little stairs
or whatever they're trying to do to get
up to the station cover and while this
is
you do not do this nope nope big nope
real-life it works like this you just
have the station covers and the same
height as the tops I'm off the floor and
that's it and that's kind of like this
but then again this is mm quite a boring
shape
so just for shape for the [ __ ] for the
purpose of having a nice shape later on
and less blocky and squarey
boring looking building I'm just going
to add some little corners in there so I
can have some variations in the roof and
the walls and all that and that's pretty
much it for the preparation of the
station not really need to add anything
else yet now you'll need to do the
brakes now at least I would recommend
anyone to do the brakes now because V
like me you can build an entire coaster
spend hours on it and decide to do the
brakes at the last stage and then in the
end you forget about them this even
happened to me and sonís I think so just
to be on the safe side I would recommend
you to just do all that stuff right now
so you can get it out of the way and
then start the real deal and right now
I'm looking for that lift Hill set and I
just found it so that's great so this is
a fallback I know there's actually also
an expansion on the set or a second
version of the set where they actually
have a cover for the chain because the
chain in the game is looking a bit
boring and bland but I'll get to that
later so if I find that I'll are AB that
in a later tutorial right now I just
want to add these four back thingies now
the reason they have this and well it
should be pretty logical it's to prevent
the coaster from falling back firmly if
it slips off the cable
it might just like slide all the way
down the lift Hill and crash into the
station or whatever and it's not good it
won't be healthy for anyone so that's
why you have this fallback thing just to
be on the safe side and abut about the
pre drop and yes I've read the comments
of course I'm not a coaster expert to be
honest I'm not even a coaster
enthusiasts I just know some stuff about
it because Rock screen 3
and because tutorial and all that but
yeah indeed only old bnm coasters have a
pre drop the new ones are technological
wonders and they don't need a pre drop
but if you're building and well I just
like pre drops I guess that's it I just
like the look of pre drops of course if
you're building a modern bnm you don't
have to really build a pre drop and roll
xq 3 either but then again it should
really be a modern vm and really look
like a modern bnm at least that's my
thought of it right so um there's also
the thing that the cable runs underneath
the track like it goes up but it also
has to go down we're rollin scream 3
doesn't add that because rocking 3 is
kind of stupid
there's thankfully those a set for that
which is somewhere over here and I've
got way too many sets so I lose track of
it once in a while right found it s km
31 so that's the site you're going to
once you use to bring the cable back
down just for ya realism purposes I
suppose but it also looks pretty nice
and you can make this cable have the
same color as the track here or you can
make it have the same color as the
supports and I guess I'm going with for
the single as the track today just in
that striking mood I suppose but I don't
think it really matters that much it's
just yeah I just say you have to try
both things out and then see what looks
best so this is the way you want to run
this thing up so it has a slightly less
of a steep angle than the lift Hill so I
don't know why but I just like the look
of that I think the bnm chain return is
the best looking chain return out there
they're just some coaster types that
have their changes dangling underneath
the track and it's looking really ugly
and amateurish but vinum really makes
these chain returns look nice
though I guess you just need to leave it
up to me to just talk about those little
details that nobody else cares about
right so and then you're going to want
to use the chain return supports to
bring it back and it doesn't want to
connect here which is a kind of a
problem I guess I'll just do like this
doesn't really matter that much a thing
like a thing like that to be honest this
little bump right here it's not going to
hit the car though it's not the best
thing it's not in catastrophe or
something like that right so and with
that out of the way the only thing left
to do is the brakes now there are plenty
plenty of gate or brake covers in this
game and I actually know that there's
some kind of a track retexture or
whatever it is that will get you rid of
the in-game brakes which would be pretty
cool since yeah I've still got I'm still
stuck with these ugly in-game brakes but
oh well I don't really mind it that much
now just for the purpose of covering up
those ugly in-game brakes and the ones I
sometimes use are X I will destroy you
or X B&M coaster add-ons or what he's
also known as crypt so let's let's just
call em crypt that's a lot easier right
so block breaks so these look pretty
nice but the other way that I worked
around it which isn't all that realistic
but it's just something that I find
looking better is you're going to open
the coaster essentials brakes which is
from techno dude don't worry about this
the links are going to be in the
description and you're going to want to
take the premiere clamp and yeah I know
this is not a premiere coaster but the
only reason why I do this is to cover up
the ugly in-game brakes and then if I as
soon as I've covered up those in-game
brakes with the premiere clamp that make
them look just a bit better but still
let them have the same size and all I'm
going to add some being a magnetic
brakes around that
and I know it's not the most realistic
thing to do the most realistic thing to
do is actually find out a way to get rid
of the in-game brakes and then at the
bnm magnetic brakes write it right away
but the only problem with that is that I
haven't figured that out yet so I'm
going to try to but for now this is
actually the thing that I find looking
best and even though like I said it's
not perfectly realistic i-s it gets the
job done right so that's when I open our
CT 3 masters things I suppose no no I
don't use this set no no what am i doing
sorry I'm just confusing you right so
you don't open that set that Sun has
some cool friction wheels in it though
you might want to use those I just
provide a link just so you can check it
out right spots I want to open that same
set I just had again because it should
have been M friction wheels in it as
well here we go so I mean being our
magnetic brakes of course this this set
doesn't have any beam and friction
wheels in it right so this is actually a
combination that I find looking pretty
nice and this is the way it looks from
up close
you've got the premiere clamps covering
up the in-game things and then they're
realistic being a magnetic brakes around
nuts and it's not too bad looking right
and if you've done that and you're
really you like to live on the edge you
can also play some friction wheels wow
that's that's shocking isn't it oops I
just misplace that right so if you want
to play some friction wheels you can do
that as well open the set there I just
accidentally opened while I didn't even
have to open it yet but now I have to
open it anyway
I see t3 master a little mathematical
equation something right so we've got
some cool friction wheels in here
and yeah why should you place these I
guess in the station station could use
some friction wheels I know I'm not a
coaster expert right I just do what I
find looking good if if anyone in the
comment section is is a coaster
exponents like no don't do that please
tell me so I can tell people in the next
episode of something but this is just
this is just my general idea of it right
so that's breaks and everything all done
I think that'll be it for this up so
it's not too much but next episode we
can get some real work done I'm going to
start on the station I'm going to take a
lot more time for that I mean all the
episode so far I've only been about 15
minutes just a bit less but in the next
uh er tutorial episode I'm just going to
finish the station at least that's what
I'm going to go for so that's going to
take maybe an hour maybe two hours
knowing me so yeah I'm going to record
that and maybe upload it sooner or later
well very soon probably and well till
then